after all the hubbub and bragging about
the Trump Republican tax cuts which
would supposedly see almost everybody
earning more in their paychecks from
week to week there's a new poll now that
says a majority of Americans actually
aren't seeing more money in their
paychecks from week to week the exact
opposite of what we were told
this is CNBC's all-america economic
survey and it finds that 52% of working
adults have not seen a change in their
checks that they're aware of and I think
that that's relevant I'll get to that in
a second
32% say that they're taking home more
money since the new tax law was enacted
16% aren't sure and we were told
remember by Stephen minuchin the
Treasury Secretary that 90% of Americans
were going to see more money in their
paychecks as a result of the tax bill
and I admit that this is kind of a weird
poll because when you look at the
internals
first of all just because you're not
seeing more money doesn't mean you're
not getting it some people don't pay
attention to their paycheck from week to
week for some the change is really
really small so it's not like a
noticeable difference in how much money
you have left over at the end of the
month and even though employers were
supposed to put in place than you
withholding tables by February 15th not
everybody has right so like we use a
payroll company and the first payroll
that we ran in February or February 15th
whatever the date was the new
withholding tables were automatically in
place and everybody on our staff is
seeing a little bit more money in their
paycheck each week but that's anecdotal
right it doesn't tell us what's going on
nationally and anecdotally speaking
there are people who have also lost
quite a bit of money on the basis of not
being able to claim children in college
the question in the end is going to be
if you have a little more money or a
little less money does it make a
difference in your life for some people
it does for a lot of people it's not
money that actually makes a difference
and if that's the case then we have to
ask well was it worth going through
something so massive an overhaul of the
entire tax system endless amount of time
for our elected officials in the House
and Senate and the president and staff
all for a tiny change from
most people that allows the very rich to
get drastic cuts and what will
eventually be the effective tax rates
that they pay when they file taxes for
2018 next year and that gets to the
other point of the poll in the poll of
those who said we do have more take-home
pay only 38% say that the difference is
enough to even be fairly significant to
them that's not exactly what I would
consider a major major victory so the
biggest question is major tax cuts right
major major tax cuts for the rich tiny
changes for some working-class people by
and large not life-changing hugely
damaging to the economy over the long
term is it worth it I guess we'll see in
a few years and as far as whether it's a
voting issue we'll see in November yeah
I'd imagine for most people it's
something like $20 per pay period or $50
per pay period yeah you know I don't
want to laugh at that no that could be a
lot to someone yeah but for most of us
that think it's kind of negligible it's
kind of touchy to even talk about it
because as soon as you say these are
meaningless amounts of money you
immediately hear the Republicans who
advocated for this saying how elitist of
you to suggest that 20 bucks a pay
period for someone is meaningless for a
lot of people if they're paid every two
weeks an extra $40 a month covers
formula for their baby or whatever the
right Costco membership was the thing
that Paul Ryan or whoever was talking
about we're not saying that $40 a month
is meaningless to everyone what we're
saying is in the grand scheme of how
much money went into this how it might
affect other elements of the economy
over the long term and how much of these
savings are disproportionately going to
the very very rich the question is does
it make sense is it worth it given that
we're talking about 20 bucks a pay
period or whatever it's not laughing at
or minimizing that $20 a pay period for
someone can be meaningful it's talking
about the entire cost of this thing and
contextualizing it in terms of how much
is going to go to the very very rich and
how much actually goes to the working
class
send me your thoughts send me even just
tell me on Twitter at D Pakman have you
seen a change in
your check let me know I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's program is sponsored
in part by shaker and spoon the monthly
cocktail subscription box that delivers
the craft cocktail experience right to
your door I selected the death by gin
box for my recent delivery and I really
liked it open up the box you've got a
bunch of different ingredients that lets
you make 12 total cocktails right four
servings of three different cocktails
enough to last you an entire month
my favorite drink in the box was the
above a persimmon which I really enjoyed
making and this is a great thing because
my knowledge of cocktails is so limited
that I am basically relegated if I want
to make a cocktail to grabbing seltzer
water and combining it with vodka and
then if I have a piece of lime lemon or
orange in the fridge I'll throw that in
and the order in which I do that doesn't
really matter but if I were actually
making real craft cocktails the order of
putting together the recipe does make a
difference and you learn a lot about
mixing techniques and flavor
combinations when using the shaker and
spoon box and for a limited time you can
get $20 off by going to shaker and spoon
com slash Packman and if you're watching
this on youtube we've put a link in the
description below the video